.
Freunde der Sonne. Letzte Woche
wurde ein YouTube-Video gedroppt.
Und wenn es so etwas gäbe
wie Sience-YouTube,
wäre das auf Platz 1 der Trends.
Das ist He Jiankui.
Zumindest nenne ich ihn so,
in Wirklichkeit heißt er so:
* "He Jiankui" *
Er hat eine wissenschaftliche
Premiere für uns.
Er hat die ersten menschlichen
gen-editierten Babys
zur Welt gebracht.
Also, er hat sie nicht selbst
zur Welt gebracht. Das wär's noch.
Die Zwillingstöchter Lulu und Nana,
Pseudonyme übrigens, kamen zur Welt.
Die Eltern sind Grace und Mark.
Mark ist HIV-positiv.
He Jiankui hat jetzt ihre Eizellen
und sein Sperma genommen,
im Labor eine künstliche Befruchtung
gemacht, so weit, so normal.
Jetzt hat er dabei
aber auch noch Genom Editing,
also eine gezielte Veränderung
des Erbguts durchgeführt.
So, dass die beiden Babys sich
nicht mehr mit HIV anstecken können.
Dann hat er die Embryos
wieder der Mutter eingepflanzt,
und diese beiden Babys
wurden geboren.
Zumindest behauptet das He Jiankui.
Erst auf YouTube und ein paar Tage
später in Hongkong
auf einer großen, internationalen
Konferenz über Genom Editing.
Es war einfach so boom-ba-
what-the-fuck ist gerade passiert?
Reißen wir uns alle mal zusammen und
fragen uns: was bedeutet das jetzt?
Designerbaby-Dystopie
oder medizinischer Durchbruch?
Holt euch 'n Tee, Freunde der Sonne,
ihr habt Fragen, die klären wir.
Erst mal vielen Dank für
eure vielen Fragen und den Input.
Ich hab mir alles durchgelesen
und auf dieser Basis 10 Fragen
und Antworten zusammengestellt, die
hoffentlich vieles klarer machen.
In der Videobeschreibung
findet ihr auch Timecodes,
wo ihr zu den einzelnen Fragen
springen könnt.
Aber schaut euch lieber alles an.
Wenn es um eure Gene geht,
solltet ihr lieber Bescheid wissen.
Fangen wir an mit Nummer 1:
Genome Editing.
Was kann man damit machen?
Die Gesamtheit unserer Gene nennt
man Genom. Auf Englisch Genome.
Man kann auch einfach Erbgut sagen.
Stellt euch das Genom vor
wie eine verschlüsselte Bibliothek.
Jedes Gen besteht aus
einer Reihenfolge von Buchstaben.
In dieser Reihenfolge
ist Information kodiert.
Das ist ein Code
für alle unsere biologischen Infos,
sei es unsere Augenfarbe,
aber es können auch Sachen sein
wie Anfälligkeiten
für bestimmte Krankheiten.
Genome Editing
ist quasi Text Editing.
Textbearbeitung für die Gene.
Man kann jetzt aus einem Gen
Buchstaben rauslöschen
und neue reinschreiben.
Man kann den Code neu schreiben.
Was medizinisch ganz
schön vielversprechend sein kann,
wenn man etwa aus krank
gesund machen kann.
Wenn man denn weiß,
in welcher Buchstabensequenz
eine bestimmte Krankheit steckt.
Wahrscheinlich habt aber auch schon
von Crispr oder Crispr Cas9 gehört,
das ist eine neuere
Genome-Editing-Methode,
die einfacher, schneller, präziser
ist als die bisherigen Methoden.
Und deswegen derzeit
die Genome-Editing-Methode ist.
Wenn ich im Laufe des Videos
über Genome editieren spreche,
werde ich manchmal der Einfachheit
halber "crispern" sagen.
Und ihr wisst dann, was gemeint ist.
Das menschliche Genom
besteht aus zehntausenden Genen.
Und jedes Gen besteht aus zehn-
bis hunderttausenden Buchstaben.
Wenn man jetzt ein paar Buchstaben
hieraus verändert oder löscht,
ist das ganze immer noch,
zum Beispiel, ein Mensch.
Wir erschaffen mit Crispr
keine neue Spezies,
und ich kann mir
auch nicht einen elften Finger
oder ein Horn auf die Stirn
oder Superkräfte crispern.
2. Welches Gen wurde bei den
beiden Babys verändert und warum?
Das Gen heißt CCR5.
Und in ihm sind Informationen
über unser Immunsystem codiert.
Bei 10 % der Europäer und Amerikaner
fehlen in diesem CCR5-Gen
32 Buchstaben.
Die haben also eine Mutation
von diesem CCR5-Gen.
1 % der Menschen erbt diese Mutation
von beiden Eltern, Mutter und Vater.
Und diese Menschen
sind so ziemlich immun gegen HIV.
Angeblich wurde genau diese Mutation
im Rahmen dieser künstlichen
Befruchtung reineditiert.
Bei diesen Zwillingen.
Bei einem der Babys beide Kopien.
Bei dem anderen Baby nur eine.
3. Gibt es Nebenwirkungen?
Ja.
Crispr ist keine perfekte Methode.
Es kann zum Beispiel
Off-Target-Effekte geben.
Dass noch andere Gene außer des
gewünschten Gens verändert werden.
Es kann On-Target-Effekte geben.
Das ist, wenn an dem Gen verschiedene
Veränderungen auftreten,
nicht nur die gewünschten.
Es kann zu einem Mosaikeffekt führen,
wenn in meinem Körper,
wo jede Zelle eigentlich
dasselbe Genom tragen müsste,
verschiedene Zellen
verschiedene Genome tragen.
Um zu schauen,
ob alles gut gegangen ist,
müsste man das Genom sequenzieren,
also vollständig aufschlüsseln
und dann die Buchstabenreihenfolge
überprüfen,
ob auch wirklich alles so gelaufen
ist, wie man es sich vorgestellt hat.
Angeblich ist bei den Zwillingen
alles gut gelaufen.
Aber diese wissenschaftlichen Daten
wurden bisher noch nicht verifiziert.
Außerdem kann ein und dasselbe Gen
verschiedene Auswirkungen
auf unsere Biologie haben.
Das CCR5-Gen hat nicht nur
Auswirkungen auf HIV-Infektionen,
sondern kann die Infektionsgefahr für
andere Virusinfektionen noch erhöhen.
Etwa für die Grippe
oder den Westnil-Virus.
4. Wie groß ist
der medizinische Gewinn?
Ääääähm.
Ich sag's einfach. Nicht so groß
im Vergleich zu den Risiken.
Erstmal ging es hier nicht
um das Behandeln einer tödlichen
oder bisher unheilbaren Krankheit,
sondern um das Vorbeugen
einer behandelbaren Krankheit.
Es gibt neben Genome Editing
andere wirksame Methoden,
um sich gegen HIV zu schützen.
Wir haben es hier nicht mit
einem medizinischen Problem zu tun,
für das es bisher
keine andere Lösung gab.
Ja, HIV ist in manchen Ländern
immer noch ein verbreitetes Problem.
Und er stellt jetzt seine Arbeit dar
als Lösung des Problems.
Als eine Art genetisches Impfen.
Der Vergleich mit Impfen
ist ziemlich weit hergeholt,
vor allem
was die Machbarkeit betrifft.
Man muss hierfür eine
erfolgreiche künstliche Befruchtung
und eine erfolgreiche
Schwangerschaft schaffen
und erfolgreiches Genome Editing
ohne die Nebenwirkungen,
die wir gerade genannt haben.
Das kann man als Therapie für einen
Einzelnen vielleicht angehen.
Aber das ist sicherlich keine Lösung
für ganze Populationen.
5. Wie groß ist der medizinische
Gewinn für die Familie?
Für die Individuen, für die Eltern
und die Zwillinge?
Die Mutter Grace ist HIV-negativ,
der Vater Mark ist HIV-positiv.
Wenn du ein HIV-positiver Vater bist,
besteht die Gefahr,
dass du dein Kind bei der Zeugung
über das Sperma infizierst.
Ich empfinde das
als grenzwertig manipulativ.
Denn: bei einer künstlichen
Befruchtung kann man das HI-Virus
aus dem Sperma abwaschen,
bevor man mit dem Sperma
die Eizelle befruchtet.
Das bedeutet, Genome Editing
ist hier gar nicht nötig,
um die Infektionsgefahr
bei der Zeugung auszuschalten.
Also, ich finde
diese Unterscheidung sehr wichtig.
Es geht hier nur
um die Vorbeugung.
Dass diese Kinder sich später im
Leben nicht mit dem Virus infizieren.
Ob der Vater jetzt HIV-positiv ist,
spielt bei dieser künstlichen
Befruchtung erst mal gar keine Rolle.
Aber es spielt natürlich eine Rolle
für das Recruiting der Paare.
Denn was hier angeblich passiert ist,
das beinhaltet eine kostenlose
künstliche Befruchtung,
die normalerweise sehr teuer ist.
Und noch eine finanzielle
Entschädigung obendrauf.
Und das alleine
ist schon ein großes Problem.
Denn dieses Paar hat wahrscheinlich
einen starken Wunsch
nach einem gesunden Kind.
Und das kann dazu führen, dass sie
nicht dazu in der Lage sind,
sachlich Risiken
und Nutzen abzuwägen.
6. Können gecrisperte Gene
vererbt werden?
Ja. An Genome Editing
wird jetzt schon länger geforscht.
Aber falls das jetzt alles stimmt,
wurde hier zum ersten Mal
in die Keimbahn eingegriffen.
Das bedeutet,
dass diese Genveränderungen
auch vererbt werden können.
Das Neue ist nicht, dass hier Genome
Editing an Embryos gemacht wurde.
Das wird schon
'ne Zeit lang gemacht.
Allerdings an "in vitro"-Embryos,
das sind non-viabel Embryos,
nicht lebensfähige,
die im Labor entstehen
durch eine künstliche Befruchtung
einer Eizelle durch Sperma.
Jetzt wurden aber angeblich
zum ersten Mal solche Embryos
in den Mutterleib eingesetzt,
sind dort herangewachsen
und kamen zur Welt.
Und wenn diese Kinder
irgendwann selber Kinder zeugen,
können sie diese veränderten Gene
ganz normal vererben.
7. Warum ist dieser Eingriff
in die Keimbahn so heikel?
Wenn man jetzt irgendwas verkackt,
wenn Nebenwirkungen auftreten
und die dann noch vererbt werden,
hat man es natürlich
viel mehr verkackt,
als wenn nur
ein einzelner Mensch betroffen ist.
Man sollte also verdammt noch mal
fucking sicher sein,
bevor man in die Keimbahn eingreift.
Und diese Sicherheit
gab es hier nicht.
Außerdem geschieht so ein Genome
Editing natürlich ohne die Zustimmung
dieser Babys.
Wenn diese Babys wirklich
gecrispert geboren wurden,
hatten sie niemals die Chance, über
ihren eigenen Körper zu entscheiden.
Und selbst Risiken und Nutzen
abzuwägen. Das ist recht abgefuckt.
Das verrückte an der Meldung
ist also nicht,
dass hier etwas geschafft wurde, was
bisher technisch nicht möglich war.
Denn das war es.
Es ist eher so, dass bisher niemand
die Whatthefuckness besessen hatte,
das in die Praxis umzusetzen.
8. Besteht Grund zur Panik?
Prinzipiell schon mal nein.
Denn Panik ist nie die Lösung.
Aber vor allem haben
wir derzeit keine Ahnung,
ob Hes Behauptungen stimmen.
Wir wissen weder, ob das Ganze
wirklich so passiert ist
und falls ja,
ob es erfolgreich war.
Die wissenschaftlichen Daten
sind bisher noch nicht verifiziert
und veröffentlicht.
Wir haben hier völlige Intransparenz,
was für Wissenschaft
ein absolutes No-Go ist.
Diese Wissenschaftsbombe
hier einfach so zu droppen,
ohne verifizierbare Evidenz,
das geht nicht.
Wenn wir streng sind,
ist das keine Wissenschaft.
Alles, was das bisher ist...
Es sind Gerüchte.
George Church
von der Harvard University,
das ist einer
"der" Genetiker, hat gesagt,
dass er die Daten gesehen hat und
dass er es für wahrscheinlich hält,
dass es so passiert ist.
Aber das hilft ja alles nichts.
Wir können momentan nur spekulieren.
Und wir müssen immer sagen:
Falls das passiert ist, dann...
* sie verschluckt sich
und muss husten *
Da verschlucke ich mich direkt an
meinem Tee vor lauter Intransparenz.
9. Was sagt die wissenschaftliche
Community dazu?
Rund 120 chinesische Wissenschaftler
haben ein öffentliches
Statement unterschrieben,
in dem sie seine Experimente
aufs Schärfste verurteilen.
Seine Uni hat sich
von ihm distanziert,
betont, dass sie von
den Experimenten nichts wusste
und dass er seit Januar 2018
freigestellt war.
Internationale Kollegen,
also alle Expertinnen
und Experten auf diesem Gebiet,
beurteilen das Ganze
als vorschnell, als naiv,
als unreflektiert,
als unverantwortlich.
Es wird wahrscheinlich auch
rechtliche Konsequenzen haben.
Er musste seine Forschung einstellen.
Die chinesischen Behörden haben
Untersuchungen gegen ihn eingeleitet.
Nur, dass das auch klar ist:
He Jiankui vertritt
nicht die chinesische Wissenschaft.
Und auch sonst
keine wissenschaftliche Bewegung.
Sondern er steht derzeit ziemlich
alleine auf weiter Flur.
10. Das habt ihr auch oft gefragt:
Was sage ich dazu?
Für die Diskussion,
die wir jetzt darüber führen müssen,
ist es eigentlich egal,
ob das Ganze stimmt oder nicht.
Fakt ist, es ist technisch möglich.
Wenn es jetzt nicht passiert ist,
passiert es ein andermal.
Deswegen sollten wir ethisch,
juristisch und politisch
dafür gewappnet sein,
damit wir nicht von
der Wissenschaft überrollt werden.
Und dann irgendwann nur:
what the fuck ist gerade passiert?
Crispr ist ein scharfes,
zweischneidiges Messer,
mit dem man lebensrettende
Operationen durchführen kann
und Menschen töten kann.
Vor allem ist eines wichtig: das
menschliche Genom gehört uns allen.
Das ist kein Bereich,
in dem Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler
allein entscheiden sollten.
Deswegen ist es gut,
dass ihr euch informiert,
damit ihr mitreden könnt.
Egal, ob wir für
oder gegen Gentechnik seid,
diese Technik wird kommen.
Meinetwegen kann sich
auch Deutschland dagegen sträuben
dann wird der Rest der Welt
ohne uns mitmachen,
und uns zwangsläufig mit reinziehen.
Frage Nr.11: Was denkt ihr?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
und wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
Also. Es ist folgendes passiert:
* festliche Musik *
Mailab
hat einen Webvideo-Preis bekommen.
What the fuck ist gerade passiert?
Offensichtlich ist 2018
das Preisjahr für MaiLab.
Aber jetzt hier beim Webvideo-Preis
hab ich wirklich,
wirklich nicht damit gerechnet.
So 'ne krasse Konkurrenz,
alle in derselben Kategorie,
es gab nämlich keine.
Und es war ein Voting-Preis.
Und anscheinend
habt ihr einfach abgestimmt.
Danke. Bäm!
Ansonsten... Schauen wir mal, ob sich
Montag als Upload-Tag durchsetzt.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Montag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.